tout de suite nous mettant le cap vert
cintegabelle un petit bourg à 30 km de
toulouse dont lionel jospin vous savez
et conseiller général chaude ambiance
dans tout bon car le comme on vient ici
on se prépare bien sûr comme partout on
attend les estimations
[Applaudissements]
comme les voyages comme vous voyez
beaucoup d'impatience à quelques minutes
maintenant beaucoup d'espoir merci
carole d'un coup deux faisceaux
hertziens nous allons à du côté du sel
où sont rassemblés les sympathisants de
jacques chirac en direct avec nous
invitons baer deux minutes l'heure
fatidique
l'ambiance est très chaude comme vous
pouvez le constater on espère beaucoup
on croise les doigts dans ce bastion de
jacques chirac depuis près de 30 ans
reste quelques secondes et comme vous
l'entendez
'cela fait déjà bien merci
jef donc vous voyez sur le grand écran
qui se trouve derrière nous
la silhouette qui est en préparation
cette silhouette ce sera celle du
président du cinquième président de la
république qui va apparaître dans
quelques instants
en attendant nous allons faire un ultime
détour par l'hôtel de ville retrouvez
nathalie saint cricq voudrait pour
l'instant on attend jacques sirat attend
toujours dans son bureau et on pense que
dans quelques instants donc on va savoir
et à ce moment là jacques chirac sortira
de son bureau pour retrouver les invités
qu'ils attendent et qui devrait
l'ovationner mais on attend encore
quelques instants
roland sicard maintenant dans les
jardins de la maison de la chimie roland
vous voyez on écoute la soirée organisée
par france 2 et où l'on siffle lorsque
l'on parle de jacques chirac ou l'ont
applaudi lorsque l'on parle de lionel
jospin et où on attend et bien
l'estimation des bv a deux qui devraient
tomber d'ici quelques saisons
et vous voyez ici à la maison la chine
garde l'espoir de créer une deuxième
fois la surprise bien il nous reste un
petit peu plus de deux minutes je vais
peut être demandé à paul loup sulitzer
qui nous a rejoint qui étaient là aussi
la première semaine est ce qu'il pense
de cette de ce suspense d'abord je crois
que c'est tout à fait normal qu'ils en
suspens après les résultats du premier
tour mais je constate que le débat
présidentiel a eu au moins le mérite de
mettre les choix des français entre
l'esprit de réforme ce qu'est la volonté
des hommes qui entourent jacques chirac
et un certain conservatisme qui s'est
manifestée lors de ce débat je pense que
les français vont trancher dans le sens
de la récente vient alors messieurs qui
est réunit déjà autour de nous dans
quelques instants nous aurons à débattre
ensemble bien entendu du résultat
bernard kouchner est ce que vous pensiez
sincèrement peut on parler quand même
maintenant que monsieur jospin aller
faire la campagne qu'il a fait c'est
vrai que le parti socialiste est parti
un petit peu bas dans les sondages et un
petit peu plus perdants qui ne l'est
aujourd'hui
il est parti de très bas et il est parti
très tard et donc j'ai constaté comme
vous que non seulement la campagne de
lionel jospin était bonne mais qu'elle
répondait qu on lui répondait par un
mouvement qui s'amplifiait et qui c'est
vrai on verra tout à l'heure est venu
buter sur cette date si j'ose dire c'est
à dire que il a manqué du temps par
rapport aux autres candidats c'est tout
à fait vrai mais il n'a pas manqué de
souffle
il n'a pas manqué au compte de dimension
au contraire on a l'impression que pour
vos en tout cas gagnant ou perdant vous
l'espérez gagnant bien entendu c'est
déjà gagné
jallet employés cette formule mais je me
permettrai de l'employé à nouveau dans
vingt secondes annonce dans vienne dans
vingt secondes il est 19 heures 59 et 39
minutes 40 secondes 44 45 46
48 49 j'ai sauté le 47,50 s'agira du 22e
président depuis louis napoléon
bonaparte rappelons le est rappelons au
passage que le septennat existe depuis
il est 20 heures voici le joint des
français
le nom et le pourcentage de la victoire
pour le nouveau président de la
république cinquième président de la
vème république jacques chirac
cinquante deux pour cent des suffrages
exprimés aujourd'hui lionel jospin 48%
des suffrages exprimés
le nouveau président de la république et
donc monsieur jacques chirac élu avec 52
% des voix
c'est la joie c'est la liesse on peut le
comprendre
avenue d'iéna au siège du quartier
général de monsieur jacques chirac je
vous laisse écouter l'ambiance
[Applaudissements]
battus pour nathalie saint cricq l'hôtel
de ville où se trouvent toujours jacques
chirac
oui bien selon était calme et pour tout
dire serein c'est à l'heure c'est que
l'on savait depuis quelques minutes que
jacques chirac avait gagné après les
mauvaises surprises du premier tour ici
on considère que c'est une autre bonne
surprise et on considère là que jacques
chirac réalise un bon score brest et ce
qu'il a gagné
jacques serra qui lui attendait dans son
bureau mais le savez également un moment
devrait très vite intervenir devant
environ 1000 personnes élus militants
qui se trouve dans la salle de fêtes au
su de cette série on s'attend également
à ce que le parvis de l'hôtel de ville
qui se trouve derrière moi soit noire de
monde dans quelques instants
monsieur jacques chirac élu président de
la république réaction maintenant à la
au quartier général de monsieur jose par
la maison de la chimie roland sicard
écoutez c'est bien entendu ici une très
grosse déception déception qui tient au
fait que depuis le très bon résultat de
lionel jospin au premier tour depuis
l'arrivée en tête de lionel jospin au
premier tour et bien beaucoup de
militants socialistes s'étaient inspirés
tout simplement la victoire seulement je
dirais quand même que cette déception
est tempéré par le bon score que réalise
ce soir lionel jospin il ya trois mois
il faut bien dire qu'un tel résultat
était inespéré
et si on avait annoncé aux militants
socialistes un score de 48 % si vous
pressez d'expression il aurait signé
tout de suite d'ailleurs plusieurs
militants que j'ai croisés tout à
l'heure me l'ont dit et pour eux après
le désastre des législatives la déroute
des européennes est bien le résultat de
ce soir le redonne espoir vous le voyez
les militants socialistes malgré la
défaite garde le moral
alors beaucoup plus prêt que vous de
monsieur jospin guilaine chenu tout
juste aux côtés de monsieur jospin
réaction à l'autre étage donc de la
maison de la chimie
il elle se trouve pour le moment au
premier étage de la maison de la chimie
c'est évidemment ici aussi une immense
déception pour les socialistes il s'y
attendait un petit peu dans les derniers
jours
mais dans les dernières semaines par
contre il avait cru que la victoire
pouvait être possible à leur déception
mais aussi satisfaction de l'est car si
réduit qui existe entre les deux
candidats je n'ai juste pas un pouvoir
penser pouvoir talonner jacques chirac
c'est chose faite ce soir il en a fait
la preuve alors dans quelques instants
le n'existe pas devrait arriver ici et
faire sa déclaration nous l'attendons
vers 20h10 20h15
vous le voyez tout est prêt ici à la
tribune et tout le monde ici bien sûr là
tu en voilà après la une certaine
froideur d'un certain qg est bien
compréhensible nous allons tout de suite
à ussel dans le fief corrézien de
jacques chirac ou là je suppose que
c'est une explosion de
j'évite ambert bien sûr ici aussi le
suspense est levé et même si la plupart
des habitants du sel sont devant leur
téléviseur en ce moment ils sont comme
il l'entend ici quelques militants
particulièrement satisfaits cette salle
polyvalente va se remplir à partir de
20h30 21h on nous promet la fête
jusqu'au bout de la nuit
je termine en vous disant tu en corrèze
jacques chirac a obtenu plus de 60% des
suffrages
trop fief de monsieur jacques chirac ce
soir c'est l'avenue d'iéna où nous
retournons en compagnie de véronique
sainte oliva alors que là sur notre
écran derrière nous c'est monsieur
roland dumas si je vois bien qui est en
discussion avec jean pierre elkabbach le
président français nous pourrions
peut-être aller avenue d'iéna maintenant
écouter oui j'ai beaucoup de mal à à
pouvoir vous parler parce que je suis
débordée par les militants et les
sympathisants qui n'arrivent plus à
cacher leur leur passion et leur folie
de joie de voir le jacques chirac élu
avec cette facilité là jusqu'à la
dernière seconde il ya une véritable
incertitude
alors quand le score s'est affiché sur
d'autres écrans ça a été un véritable
délire au qg juste à côté des drapeaux
sont déployés la foule chante la
marseillaise et vous les entendez
maintenant la seule chose qu'il répète à
l'envi ses on a gagné on a gagné
voilà je ne savais pas que les paroles
de la marseillaise était à commencer par
mon a gagné mais il ya des choses qui
changent et qui évoluent au cours de la
cinquième république
ambiance maintenant à cintegabelle dans
le fief de monsieur lionel jospin
là bas je suppose que c'est un petit peu
moins gai n'ont qu'à rome oui
effectivement c'est une cabale celle de
bel et bien sûr déçu ce soir comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer les résultats à 20h ou
d'ailleurs été accueillie ici par des
bus et cintegabelle qui est resté fidèle
à son conseiller général aujourd'hui
puisqu'elle lui est accordée 63% de ses
suffrages déception mais pas morosité
pour autant lionel jospin a réalisé une
belle performance en très peu de temps
peut disais tout à l'heure une habitante
du village tous les militants j'aurais
unis maintenant dans cette salle des
fêtes de cintegabelle où nous nous
trouvons tous on l'attention devait hier
un peu ce soir mais peut-être pas aussi
tard qu'ils auraient pu l'espérer bien
merci beaucoup carole je vous propose je
vous rappelle tout d'abord l'estimation
bv a que nous vous donnions à 20h très
très précise jacques chirac élu
président de la république avec 52% des
suffrages exprimés
lionel jospin obtenant 48% des suffrages
exprimés chiffres également important
sur lequel nous reviendrons tout au long
de cette soirée est les blancs et nuls
totalisent près de 5% c'est un événement
politique très important et je vous
signale que les autres instituts de
sondage donnent en gros les mêmes
chiffres et confirme donc la victoire de
jacques chirac donc avec ce chiffre aux
alentours de 50 2% un rapide commentaire
à la 10 e mail la victoire de jacques
chirac signifie d'abord que la france va
changer de phase et de périodes
politiques
après 14 ans qui ont été dominés par la
personnalité de françois mitterrand
c'est une période nouvelle qui va
commencer
c'est un président de la république
d'origine gaulliste qui va se trouver de
nouveau à l'elysée ce qui ne s'était pas
passé depuis 21 ans dans cette
république d'origine gaullienne le score
de jacques chirac que peut paraître
relativement étroit il est en réalité
tout à fait comparable à celui de
françois mitterrand en 1981
ça signifie que pour le second tour la
discipline à l'intérieur de la
droite parlementaire a bien joué et
effectivement comme on le signalait à
l'instant l'importance des votes nuls
signifie bien que les consignes de jean
marie le pen s'adressant à son électorat
ont été partiellement suivie pour le
reste il faut relever que lionel jospin
a réussi une bonne performance une bonne
campagne qu'il a obtenu un score qui
était il faut le dire
inimaginable pour la gauche il ya
maintenant en réalité un mois seulement
et que de ce point de vue jours a
inévitablement un rôle à l'intérieur de
l'opposition on peut dire que d'une
certaine manière ce soir la france a à
la fois un nouveau président et un
nouveau leader de l'opposition et puis
pour terminer je dirai qu'il ne faut pas
que ce second tour face oublier le
premier le second tour c'est normal est
un tour politique et électoral le
premier tour a été un tour d'abord
sociale qui a montré que les attentes
des français était importante
jacques chirac pour sa part avait
réalisé sa percée autour d'une
rhétorique de changement il a ensuite
mené sa campagne autour d'une idéologie
de changement maintenant qu'il est élu
président de la république il lui faudra
certainement une politique de changement
merci alain nous allons maintenant nous
rendre quelques instants à l'hôtel de
ville vous allez voir la grande salle
des fêtes est archi plein on attend d'un
instant à l'autre l'arrivée de monsieur
jacques chirac y est le nouveau
président de la république
ensuite nous allons nous rendre au
quartier général de monsieur chirac
toujours sur ces mêmes images qui se
trouve avenue d'iéna là aussi les
militants sont réunis à la fois dans la
rue et dans le bâtiment qui servait de
quartier général de monsieur jacques
chirac véronique oui eh bien alors ici
la joie ne s'arrête pas les militants
attendent impatiemment la déclaration de
jacques chirac
vous les entendez sont extrêmement ils
ont la joie extrêmement bruyante
après sa déclaration jacques chirac
devrait les rejoindre ici
retrouvera philippe séguin et alain
juppé qui sont là depuis une petite
heure et puis il devrait également
rencontrer un certain nombre d'amis et
de sympathisants
de l'autre côté de la rue avant de se
rendre dans son qg pour remercier toute
l'équipe qui s'est occupé de sa campagne
présidentielle
[Musique]